what's going on inside the head of
someone that can go beyond themselves
it's I think that's something that you
can't necessarily
uh consciously control so all these
other factors are coming into play let's
say it's you know it's the Olympics and
you're running that final race and
just being in that environment you know
with the audience and the lights and the
camera whatever is there is motivating
your body I mean we see this in in
cockroaches okay
okay so I was not expecting that
[Music]
this is star talk sports edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson here your host and your
personal astrophysicist and today we're
gonna address issues that relate to your
power and strength of Mind especially
with regard to high performance athletes
but of course advice there could
probably apply to all of us at all times
I got with me my co-host Chuck Nice Jack
hey Neil all right uh it didn't work I
was trying to use my mind to move some
stuff in your in your whole room yeah no
it didn't work no yeah I was trying to
tap it to the force man yeah if you can
do that you were in the wrong profession
at this moment okay and I got Gary Riley
Gary hi Neil and I'm practicing nothing
right now just good being stationary
thank you I like a stable world please
thank you uh Gary is a former Soccer Pro
in the UK and soccer announcer what did
you have in mind for this episode
um so we we regularly look to the elite
athletes to display the kind of
supercharged performance
and navigate under intense pressure we
want them to have unbreakable
concentration we want them to have off
the chart cognitive skills
but what if you're not one of these
Elite athletes what if you're a first
responder what if you're a surgeon a
police officer a lawyer a pilot
a single parent of three are the demands
on your strength of mind not as intense
so
how do I develop this type of mindset
how do I maintain this type of mindset
right they're the questions this we need
answers so who are you going to call the
good doctor Dr Heather Berlin
yay a good friend to start talk but a
neuroscientist clinical psychologist
associate professor of Psychiatry and
Neuroscience at the icann school of
medicine at Mount Sinai New York so is
eminently qualified to guide us through
this particular area of science I love
that you turned her a school of medicine
into a positive affirmation the I can
school
I do my best I do my best I see ah
Heather how do you pronounce that boy's
name icon
yes right tomato tomato
that's how you'd say it in the UK
probably yeah I can't well I believe I
can't
hear I believe I can't
um
all right so I for especially up during
any game or any contest in in High Level
Sports but especially in playoffs and in
the final games uh the coaches will
always tell you you need a winning state
of mind uh and you know just like in
life and that's an interesting sort of
extra thing that player is going to have
to worry about beyond their physical
conditioning after they spend all those
hours in the gym running up and down
stairs whatever it is and so so what
makes some people better
at focus of Mind than others and can you
train this is this something that that
oh while I'm in the gym you know pumping
iron or whatever I'm doing is there
something else I can do with my mind so
that in the moment when the time comes I
am ready yeah yeah I mean just like
muscles in your body you know the mind
or the brain you can think of it like a
muscle right and the more you exercise
certain skills the more you can develop
them now there are individual
differences in our ability to say to
focus our attention or to sort of ignore
negative thoughts or counter productive
thoughts that you might be having that
can interfere with your performance but
there's a level of kind of cognitive
control that we need in order to
maintain focus and kind of dismiss these
negative thoughts that might pop into
our minds and you can practice this
skill and there are particular Parts in
the frontal lobe that you can use to
gain strength let's say
um in this cognitive capacity just to be
clear it's not just negative thoughts
it's just distracting thoughts right any
thought that takes you away from where
you are it wouldn't even have to be
negative I presume yes and one of the
one of the practices is mindfulness and
mindful meditation where you have a
thought and sort of it could be a
thought that's not relevant to the game
or a negative thought and you just let
it pass like a cloud passing by you
don't attach to it you don't let it take
you down another path where you get
distracted so we can't stop these
intrusive thoughts from coming in but
you can allow them to pass and not sort
of attend to them so that you can
maintain the focus on the thing you need
to be paying attention to in that moment
so is that why individual stress levels
vary
because they've attached themselves to
this passing Cloud rather than just let
it fly by because interesting you hear
people say all the time I've had enough
well who decides that you know what's
what what is it that's gone on in your
mind that's decided that that's the
point that that's your Corrections yeah
so here's the thing there are two things
one is that there are individual
differences in terms of our what we call
like tolerance
um for distress okay so some people have
a higher threshold they can maintain a
lot of
um stress and not sort of break other
threshold is lower but yes anybody who
follows let's say one of these negative
thoughts down a path you know let's say
the thought is I'm not good enough and
then it goes to oh I'm not good enough
that means I'm going to do terrible in
this game and I'm gonna lose and the
whole team's gonna be disappointed in me
and on and on and on of course anybody
would start to get upset by those
thoughts so the more you follow them and
let them lead you down this negative
thought path the more likely you are
going to get more stressed out so the
idea is to have a negative thought and
just Just Let It Go and Keep redirecting
your attention to something positive
order the task at hand you know I gotta
catch this ball right I can't let that
thought take me away so I keep hearing
in my head I keep your head don't worry
be happy yeah that works
but actually music music can
um there are a bunch of studies that
show that music can actually change your
mood and help you adapt to stress and
people are like nurse sizes are working
together to create playlists that can
either help increase your attention and
focus or put you in a better mood so
music Heather we saw that in the
Olympics where the the guys coming out
you know the swimmers were coming out
and everybody had their little
headphones on you know and you wonder
what are they listening to I Want To
Know music I hate to interrupt can we uh
can we just sing another song I can't
get that damn song out of my head now
all right so okay we've we've just
planted a few ear worms uh for sure but
one thing to think about music is that
it does um impact the subcortical
evolutionarily older parts of your brain
like the basal ganglion the emotional
Center that are below the cortex and
that's why for example with Alzheimer's
when they're having dementia and like
the sort of decreased um cortex if you
play music for them it can recreate them
because it's these more subcortical
deeper I've heard about that yeah it's
pretty cool yeah was it Oliver Sacks
that went down that route with music
music failure yes yeah there was there
was a film on it so Tony Bennett Tony
Bennett had Advanced dementia and was
able to sing all of his songs if you
started him off all you had to do was I
love my heart and then he would boom
right into it yeah because it's
instantiated in the brain like riding a
bike once you hit that the basal ganglia
it's like this sort of it automatically
just goes like you flow into it you
don't have to think about it Heather
just spend a minute about what is the
basal ganglia it's a complex subcortical
structure and it's broken up into
different parts but it's involved in
what we call implicit memory especially
motor memory so when you're first
learning to ride a bike you have to
think about it right you're using your
cortex and once it becomes after
practice it becomes automatic then it
gets moved into that basal ganglia which
means you don't have to think about it
the next time you ride a bike and and
then but that's also the part of the
brain that's affected in Parkinson's
disease
um and and so it's involved in lots of
different things but if you think about
automatic behaviors that we need to not
be able to think about like walking we
can't always have to think about how to
walk right basal ganglia will control
that but music sort of it gets
instituted in that part of the brain
yeah and you know what's cool is uh all
this what Heather's when you talked
about underneath it might be important
to talk to the audience about the layer
cake of the brain the because that's
something I learned from Heather in just
a offline conversation that I did not
know about that your brain is built
platform on top of platform on top of
platform because of evolution right yes
that is how it evolves you explained it
just better than me I mean I should ask
you the questions
um but yeah I mean sometimes the the
this the subcritical structures are
called The Reptilian Brain or the lizard
brain oh yeah this limbic system that's
like your raw Sensations like emotions
um anger
um and and it's when animals other
animals have to act on reflex and
respond to their environment very
quickly without this thinking about the
consequences that's the parts of the
brain that we have inherited from our
other animal ancestors but then we start
evolving this larger layer this cortex
which allows us to feel those impulses
but then decide whether we want to act
on them or not and that gives us more
control over our Behavior but it also
gives us more responsibility we're more
responsible for actions doctor I must
ask you
um as in Life or in sport the ability to
have unbreakable concentration is
is vital in certain moments why is it
that some people have it and some people
just get distracted by anything and
everything
it really has a lot to do with that
ability to have cognitive control right
there's a part of the wrinkle the answer
is singular uh singular that has to do
with like when there's conflict when
there's different things that you can
pay attention to some people are able to
tune it out and remain focused but if
you don't have a lot of cognitive
control if you haven't exercised these
parts of your brain or you just happen
to be genetically born with you know
wired differently or smaller prefrontal
cortex or anterior cingulate you have a
more difficult time tuning out the noise
so that you can focus on the signal so
it's like people with ADHD they get very
easily distracted hello yeah the people
who are squirrel squirrel but yeah I
mean that the thing I think that the
people who are Elite Sports players
might be the types of people that have a
greater ability to do that and then they
go on to sort of perfect that skill
right so if you're just so distracted
all the time you might be really good
athletically physically but you're not
able to keep your head in the game and
you won't make it to those Elite levels
that is absolutely true why is
concentrating so exhausting take it take
speaking as somebody who suffers off the
charts ADHD I mean literally off the
charts uh you know when I concentrate
for long periods of time I'm literally
fit I am physically tired when it's over
what is happening so because it's an
active process it's your prefrontal
cortex has to be activated to decrease
the activation that's happening in those
subcortical like animalistic areas and
it's a constant process and the second
you let go of that you you let go of
that suppression by the prefrontal
cortex it allows all the impulses to
come up so for example if you're sleep
deprived if you're you're hungry
um if you've been drinking all those
things lower the prefrontal cortex
activation and allow these impulses to
kind of take over right but if you're
somebody who's prone to
um let's say your limbic system is
louder and stronger than some other
people so it's further for you to
control it it takes more cognitive
energy and therefore you're more tired
at the end of the day I'm a construction
man she just called you a reptile
I'm a dumbass caveman
reptilian cavemen you're not even a
caveman you're a reptile that's true
I'm a sleep stack
thank you
but let me say one thing let me say one
caveat some people who are the opposite
problem when they're over controlled
when they have too much prefrontal
cortex activation of other types of
problems they ruminate a lot they're
over anxious they they can barely
function because they keep thinking
about the potential negative
consequences of things and therefore
they they can't be spontaneous so
they're inflexible so there can be
problems on the other side of the
spectrum as well it's all about balance
okay all right is there a way that you
can balance or are you just stuck with
whatever you've got yeah
interesting therapy um no you know okay
look at that nice little plug for
Heather's Christmas
all right are you having trouble
concentrating
um but everybody if you think of it like
your your genetics um predict like what
your your boundaries are where are you
where you're at and then with therapy or
practice you can get to a higher or
lower level within your genetic bounds
right so so Chuck for example if you if
you lean more on the sort of impulsive
spontaneous side which is good because
it helps with you know being a good
comedian but maybe for other things it's
not that helpful yeah like marriage
you can you can work on being more
consciously like cognizant of those
behaviors and it just takes more work
for you to think about it and then
actively sort of engage your prefrontal
cortex to suppress some of those
impulses just to be clear do you imply
that since alcohol is one of several
factors that could disrupt the ability
of your frontal cortex to Tamp down your
your limbic impulses impulses that when
you see bar fights break out it's
because people's frontal
prefrontal cortex was losing control
over The Reptilian urges and if that's
the case does that imply that word not
for a prefrontal cortex we would all
just be bar fighting all the time we
pretty much yes okay well I mean if you
look at patients that have uh damage to
their prefrontal cortex or brain lesions
it expresses itself in different ways
it's not always physical violence but it
could be that they have these verbal
outbursts you know they're just they
don't have any filter on what they say
or they engage other impulsive acts like
um that would get them into trouble that
if they otherwise had a prefrontal
cortex you know they wouldn't just like
this all the stupid things you do if
you've ever been drunk right right right
no all those things are normally
suppressed by the prefrontal cortex but
when you lower that inhibition it allows
all these basal basic impulses to come
out um so whether it's alcohol brain
damage yeah look at that I have brain
damage and I'm drunk right now
that means it's time to take a break
all right when he returned in this first
interlude uh for Star talk sports
edition we're talking about the power of
mind not to move objects but to focus
and to concentrate and to perform when
we return we're going to find out what
role your ego plays in this and More in
Heather Berlin I want to call our
special guest but she's like a regular
guest so our beloved guest uh Heather
Berlin a neuroscientist when we return
we're back start talk sports edition how
the focus of mind can enhance or
subtract from any attempt to perform
at your Peak be it in everyday life or
in any sports venue and we've got
Heather Berlin our resident
neuroscientist uh as a as our guest
today so so Heather when people have
um egos
this is they think maybe they think
exactly what they should of themselves
but often when we say someone's got an
ego they think more highly of themselves
can that have a benefit to their
performance is this something that that
can manifest
uh in in when it's game time under
pressure does it work in Reverse
um yeah oh yeah yeah if you don't think
you're good do you end up performing
worse than you can or should have just
wondering the really this is a very
complex question actually and it touches
upon some 40 and things as well but so
what you know when we say ego you can
think of it like it's your sense of self
right and some people can have an
inflated sense of self some people can
can have a low sense of self and and
devalue themselves
um you know the ideal is to be somewhere
in the middle now to have
self-confidence is positive right so I
think that will help your performance to
feel I'm going to go out there and I
know I can do this I've done this before
it's sort of like positive self-talk and
self-confidence is good but when you get
to these in people the inflated ego
there's something called a vulnerable
narcissist and these are people that
have a lot of luster but it's really
really to cover up their insecurity and
vulnerability
and so I when somebody is too over the
top about themselves to me that is a
sign that they're actually very insecure
so the secure people with a very healthy
ego don't don't have don't have to over
advertise it they just have a sense of
like almost peace and stability within
themselves they feel comfortable in
their own skin so Heather
um are there tools of the psychologist
psychiatrists to manage a person's ego
or is it do you just talk them down from
that and and you have to talk people up
if they think lowly of themselves right
yeah what are your tactics okay so there
are a couple things first of all when
you get people on really high on the The
Narcissist scale they're very difficult
to treat and there's something called
narcissistic personality disorder which
basically is a lifetime disorder and
they often don't come for treatment
because they don't think they have a
problem everyone else they have a
problem but they don't right so they
don't want to change so they're very
difficult to treat it's easier to lift
someone up who has low self-esteem
um but
you know one thing that what would you
work with people on is when they want to
keep their head in the game or whether
it's playing a game or giving a talk or
whatever is to when you're in the moment
to become less self-aware so there's a
part of your brain
um this dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex
that has to do with your sense of self
and if you're trying to perform and
you're constantly thinking how am I
doing how am I throwing the ball what
are people thinking that messes up your
performance and so the cool idea is to
try to decrease your sense of self and
be really in the Flow State and be in
the moment and then you perform your
best so that's what I guess that's why a
lot of coaches will tell you and they
don't mean it as a cliche
go have fun like get out there and play
the game and have fun because in doing
so you take yourself out of that
equation if you're just really enjoying
yourself you're probably going to have a
pretty good perform a very good
performance what's the word flow is is a
big word today in everything and music
you know the one thing Neil you'll hear
an athlete say quite often a basketball
player
get out of your own head
your roadblocks are up here because
you've done everything you need to do to
be an elite athlete what's going on must
be between your ears so it's there oh I
missed this free shot before Oh I didn't
make that part we didn't play well here
last time I played it everything comes
in here and Doctor how do you
deconstruct that how do you get that
baggage out of that person's mind and it
could be
a lawyer like I say a first responder
how do you remove that baggage and
successfully leave it to one side
it's a little counter-intuitive because
the moment you see to somebody
don't think about those negative
thoughts they're just going to keep
thinking about anything it's like
someone who has insomnia and they keep
thinking I can't sleep I can't sleep why
I can't sleep right what you have to do
is think of something else besides sleep
get distracted you know read a book and
then you accidentally fall asleep but
the more you think about not doing it
the harder it gets and so if you can
kind of distract yourself or one one
strategy is let's say it's a big game
um so just pretend it's a practice you
know okay this is just you know like I
would do it because that takes the
pressure off and then you know decreases
all the negative thoughts or for example
academically I I remember you know there
was a couple classes you could take past
fail and I always would get like an A in
those classes because I didn't like care
as much what a waste
it happened to me once I'll never forget
it that's why I'm talking about it here
this therapy but you know the one class
I decided to take tell us about it
Heather tell us in the one I took for
credit and an A in the past fail one and
I was so frustrated but you know the
less you question well let's explore
that Heather how did that really make
you feel yes wow
it's very disappointing myself yes yes
that was environmental health and the
other was adolescent health and I'm not
going to tell you which is what but I
was quite disappointed in myself you
mentioned environmental because we've
discussed here what goes on here right
by dealing with what goes on in here
what if and you I find it now in in the
modern stadiums that have been
constructed particularly for my sports
soccer football if you wish player
lounges that they can go and sit in
before they they start before kickoff
are constructed to give psychological
boosts it might be through subliminal
paneling in the shape of a hexagon it
might be through colorways it might be
through lighting now is this hogwash and
it's just the emperor's new clothes or
actually does this provide the
psychological boost everybody is hoping
it will is that related to feng shui
where just the feeling of a space can
affect you emotionally yes so so I don't
know the specifics about those
particular rules but I do know that the
environment can definitely affect your
mood and your behavior and we've all
experienced that you know sometimes like
at schools now they have some um at my
kids school they have something called
the zenden and if a kid is feeling
stressed yeah
yeah let me tell you something that's a
rich white school right there
and I'm telling you right now
okay Jamal you need to go to the Zen Den
right now Jamal okay all right
[Laughter]
how much you paying for that school
Heather
well not disgustness
somebody's making too much money in her
practice
oh okay you know my kids it was a
timeout in the corner so speaking of Zen
Den okay go on but the point is that you
know or if you if you well I don't know
if you've ever gone to a spa or someone
you know you go to a place the music the
lighting the furniture the food smells
yeah because your brain is taking in all
these sensory information I mean it's
black and such a brain it doesn't see or
hear or feel anything it's just getting
these sensory signals and creating a
perception interpreting what your mood
should be so if it's getting a lot of
loud noises and and screaming and
yelling it's gonna affect your brain in
a certain way if it's having soothing
you know calm it will your brain will
interpret like oh I am in a safe
environment everything is okay there's
no need to have to put my fight or
flight system you know into effect right
and so this these environments do have
an impact now whether it's you know is
it this color or that color or whatnot
you know I don't know the specifics but
I do know the environment certainly has
an impact on how you feel and how you
behave that's funny because I read an
article about
um psychological torture so in America
we're not supposed to psychologically
we're not supposed to torture anybody
like you know enhance interrogation but
what they found was what they could do
is take the environment in which a
detainee is held
and make it so disconcerting that it
would screw with their head and that
they would begin to want to tell you
anything just not to be in this place
anymore so they would like make the
walls different sizes at different
places so that there was no symmetry or
they would use certain color schemes or
I mean I you know I didn't know if that
stuff was real but Gary did they do this
to the opponent's locker room
um
there was one team we played uh they're
in the Premier League right now Leeds
United they have they still have a
rather old stadium when you went to the
visiting teams locker room dressing room
right
there were no toilet facilities in that
area you had to walk out of the locker
room down a corridor and into
a more public toilet facility
so it was all psychological questions
ego right there oh yeah that's just you
know what you need to do use the
bathroom whatever it is it was
everything that was done to try and just
tweak your performance and take it down
well wait so Heather Heather in that
okay Heather
so you know
[Laughter]
um at what point does it take you down
and at what point does it boost you back
up because I tell the story and I'm
going to say it again here and now a
friend of my father's my father ran
track a friend of his
um they went for the Pioneer Club which
um hosted the blacks and Jews who were
not admitted to the New York Athletic
Club okay A friend of his Johnny Johnson
one of his black friends who ran yeah
okay
[Laughter]
he's coming around the back stretch and
there's a runner from the New York
Athletic Club several Paces behind him
going into the straightaway the coach
for the New York Athletic Club runs down
the line said this like in the 1950s
says to him catch that [__]
and my father's friend overheard this
and said
this is one [__] he ain't gonna catch
that's right and extended his lead and
so so so in terms of motivating forces
you could think you're beating someone
down when you're just making them mad
and you making now they now they want to
beat you all the more so can you know
which is which
it really depends on the individual and
what motivates them right so somebody
could hear that and get really defeated
by it if they have maybe some low
self-esteem right feeling insecure and
then they hear that and then that you
know just completely crushes them and
they feel that oh maybe I can't do it
right but it sounds like you know your
dad had had a high you know sense of
self his whole generation I mean
responded the same way for sure
self-worth and and so that is motivating
right so it can hit people in different
ways depending on what their underlying
sort of psychological profile is okay
because
let's also keep in mind it was the 50s
nothing would make a black man run
faster than hearing a white man behind
them screaming the n-word
but this is this deck doctor this is the
basis of trash talking I mean I've seen
head coaches before a game try and trash
talk some of my teammates now he didn't
realize
just how quick and sharp they were and
these were black players with attitude
and they tore him to pieces before the
game and they just came and said that
joker just tried to Trash Talk us what
an idiot right what are we going to do
about it really yeah we are going to so
destroy this team today this is the way
it spins itself around and some people
if if you know the characteristic of
certain individuals on the other team
you'll go there you will go there
knowing that that will destroy their
performance levels enough for you to
find them as a weakness will you learn
to never Trash Talk Michael Jordan yeah
or or Kobe who was the guy that we had
on he was a NBA player and he played
with Kobe but he tells the story of how
Kobe scored 50 because before the game
this other player was talking a bunch of
smack to him and Kobe was silent the
entire time that he was talking this he
was saving it up and then when the game
started yeah Kobe got the opening jump
ball went down shot all met turned to
them and went
. oh no no he didn't and then the next
time he scored he went 46. no he didn't
and I found it backwards from 50 and
ended up scoring 50 in that game oh man
oh anger is a motivator right so if
somebody you know insults you and you
and that gives you fire in your belly
that can motivate you you know kind of
like a revenge or I'll show them but I
think the best kind of well not that I
want to teach people how to
psychological torture but um
however the best place however magical
torture I said I paused
um but if you really want to disturb
your teammates instead of insulting them
which could motivate them you know like
we've just shown is to give them very
um it's this subtle manipulation it's an
uncomfortable environment you know like
we're talking about have it be you know
they they fly you know in the
uncomfortable plane seats and then
they're in these rooms that are like
small and claustrophobic and they're
asymmetrical and there's loud noises and
bright lights and all these things that
set off your nervous system to
destabilize you so when you're
uncomfortable or uncertain uncertain
about things that makes people
destabilized and can accept their
performance by the way that was a major
plot point in the movie Major League
um where the the owner didn't want to
win the championship so she would move
from Cleveland Ohio
and she uh made him take buses instead
of the planes uh took off took away the
hot water in the club in the clubhouse
and started diminishing their perks and
that just got him angry at that point
but but it's a movie so yeah right but
you see what Chuck was relaying there
about Kobe Bryant
a it's the motivation to turn it into
what is a negative to turn it into a
positive but you talked earlier on
doctor about the cortex overriding
certain decision making that was
prehistoric and his
and for him to be able to go I got this
and be in total control oh there it is
is this real smart in-game intelligence
that you find some Elite athletes just
can dial up instantly just like well in
our next segment we gotta take a break
but we're going to talk about in-game
intelligence there you go and intuition
and other things that look natural and
is it learned is it just practice is it
they're born with it we're going to find
that out when we return with Heather
Berlin talking about focus of mind and
life and especially in sports on
StarTalk
we're back start talk third and final
segment with our guest Heather Berlin
neuroscientist and friend of Star Talk
and of course I got Chuck and Gary uh
Heather how do are you active on social
media what are you what are you up to I
am I am on Twitter and Instagram Heather
underscore Berlin so so Heather uh we
want to learn about sort of Court
intuition field Intuition or uh
intelligence uh uh Sports IQ if you want
to call it that and is there anything we
should know or be able to think about
this holding aside that there's a racist
Dimension to this occasionally okay
um do you remember Jeremy Lin the
basketball player
um Lin sanity Lynn sanity okay uh he was
really good on the court and had some
very high scoring games and he played
for eight seasons or something mostly
with the New York Knicks
um the the newscasters kept saying oh he
has that look at that Court IQ that he
has and he's he's a smart but everyone
talk about how smart he is whereas
they're black players who could easily
outperform him and no one ever says they
have high court IQ so this is a this is
a bias that is deep within our culture
if a if a black athlete performs it's
natural whereas if a white athlete or
especially Asian in this case performs
well they've studied it and they they're
a student of the field and they have an
icon so holding all of that aside
because that's a separate show if we
were going to go there because I I don't
like playing the race card like Chuck
always does of course
Jeremy Lin look at him just doing
geometry geometry brackets yeah but but
all the other black players that are
sinking the same buckets they're not
doing geometry apparently okay it's just
natural so what I'm what I'm what I want
to ask you is the people who seem to
just know
and anticipate and they're all in can
you
learn that it seems to me if you could
learn it then everyone would have it but
everyone doesn't have it so maybe
there's something not true there's got
to be something that set those guys
apart right
so what I would say is this is actually
it it it can't be learned specifically
but it can by proxy and by that I mean
there's such complex such a complex
skill set that you can't think about it
consciously so what the players do what
I think is happening is when you
practice so much because your
unconscious can process much more
information than Consciousness
Consciousness is very limited so if you
had to think at every moment what angle
should I hit that ball into the net at
and what exactly you you couldn't do it
that but if you had enough practice
you're unconscious had enough
information to be able to do all the
calculations and figure out where should
I be on the court who should I pass it
to without you having to consciously
think about it that's the skill set it's
when it's so over rehearsed that things
start to become implicit that you have a
kind of intelligence but it's not a
conscious one it's unconscious and you I
just want to repeat what you said you
said your unconscious awareness
can be aware of way more that's going on
than your conscious awareness so the
more you can Hammer what is might be a
difficult task to learn the more you can
Hammer that Tamp that into your
subconscious the more effective you'll
be in your Venue is that a fair exactly
exactly so that's the same thing with
with the improvisers learning an
instrument
press practice practice learn all the
skills and the intricacies and then
relegate it to your unconscious where
you can make beautiful you know
improvised music but the best
improvisers are the ones that have
practiced the actual you know skills the
most relegated to the unconscious and
let the unconscious take it away and do
what it wants but the moment you start
thinking too much about it you actually
limit yourself so this this this I can
actually relate to not because I was an
elite athlete but not because you don't
think right but that as well but you say
the things if if you've got the toolkit
as a skill set and it's it's got so many
different things for the solutions that
the problems you have in front of you
you know you've got that that's a real
confidence boost going back to what we
were talking about earlier on you don't
have to have that self-doubt you know
you've got this no matter what comes at
you then you're using your own site to
be able to analyze what it is that has
to happen the situation you're in and
then you improvise that skill to deliver
something maybe a three-point shot maybe
a two-point shot maybe a sneaky little
past that no one else but you has seen
because you've seen a runner off to the
side of the court and you put a little
ball behind your back between your legs
and up and over there and it's like
everyone's like wow the only person that
saw that was you and we're set up here
in the crowd and we couldn't even see
that ourselves so all of this is going
off at a rate of knots that is just
ridiculous
and the less you have to think about the
more you relate to the unconscious the
less you have to think moment and the
more you can pay attention to other
things right yeah that gives you a like
a greater repertoire of possible things
to do like that makes a lot of sense
because so Odell Beckham Jr at the time
I don't know how many years ago made a
one-handed catch that was like
considered one of the greatest
one-handed snags in all of football this
is as he fell into the end zone as he
fell into the end zone and he stretched
backwards and he's all and it's just
incredible to watch but since then
one hand it catches happened three four
three or four times a game in almost
every game they're a thing and and it's
because all the receivers practice one
hand to catch us now okay they all
practice that it's it's so funny
um part of yeah it's become a tool
within their toolkit that they can but
this is I do think the confidence comes
in for example you know I know it from
my field academically you know you study
years and years and years of the brain
and then you go into a situation and
it's like well any question can be asked
I don't know what question but you trust
I have enough let's say practice or
enough I've you know knowledge base that
I'm confident that I could probably
figure out an answer to something and
it's the same thing with going on in the
court you've had enough practice and
experience of different moves and shots
and things that you figure anything they
throw at me I'll I'll be able to throw
something out you know I'll have an I'll
have a response to it and that's what I
think the great athletes have is they
just have they don't have to think about
the response it just comes based on all
the years of practice do you know the
other thing that's developed new with
with team sports maybe basketball
definitely with NFL and in my game my
game of football is pattern recognition
when this this this happens I know I
need to be here to stop this or I need
to be here to facilitate a pass into me
so I can set this other thing up and you
practice a new train but now and again
someone comes along and just breaks the
mold but what is it doctor when you've
got pattern recognition going on in the
head what what makes it so
sharp and then go back to Neil's Point
intuitive you've got that history of
knowledge of research and then boom you
can execute it immediately again your
your brain is like a meaning maker
machine and it's always looking for
patterns I mean that's what we do every
day in our life is pattern recognition
so we can predict the future right so if
you're doing it within a particular
domain of sports you've been doing it
over and over and over again you start
to get attuned to that but what I did
find I I once in in my career I was
doing
um the neuropsych testing of of NFL
players and so both Baseline and then
after they have a concussion to see if
they're able to go back in the game and
the interesting thing that I found not
you know being a person who's very into
sport you know there's this cliche that
people who play sports you know or like
jocks and not necessarily the brightest
obviously a stereotype and when I give
them these neurocyte tests they perform
so well they were so good at like at
speed and accuracy of cognitive tasks
you know and that was when I realized
that that is part of the skill set it's
not just the physical prowess it's a
really smart and capable and and and
that's part of being a good athlete it's
not an academic smartness is it doctor
there's another there's this game
intelligence there's this I would say
that there it is an academic smartness
simply it's just applied to the game
because I don't know if anybody's ever
seen an NFL Playbook but it looks like
the kind of stuff Neil and his brood
right up on chalkboards it's ridiculous
well but let me see the difference
between accent academic tests which are
knowledge of facts how much you know do
you know about history and whatever
um and if you haven't had a certain type
of education you might not do well on
those tasks right you haven't been
exposed to that information that's what
I really meant that kind of yeah well
these kinds of tests these neuropsych
tests are kind of like or IQ tests you
can't study for them they're based on
basic like like mental rotation of
shapes those skill sets are are natural
abilities of the brain those are the
kinds of things we're looking at speed
how fastly can you trace this thing you
know
um and or fluidity mental fluidity and
and they score really high on these
kinds of things so could could if you
were able to develop and sharpen your
intuition
as an athlete as a team sport
would that be of benefit to take that
kind of application into other
professions to to enhance the
performances of of doctors lawyers
surgeons Etc you know I I would say this
and unfortunately there's no sort of
quick fix the best way to sharpen your
intuition is with experience and
ultimately it's wisdom so if in my field
if I have seen enough patience and
enough you know
um think I can read people very quickly
because of years of experience and
practice and I think then you get a
sense of intuition intuition is your
unconscious feeding up serving up to
your Consciousness information it's
saying or there's you know I'm not
consciously thinking about it something
will pop up and be like oh that's a red
flag on that person or I think they
might have OCD or whatever it is and the
same thing in sports it's years of
experience that that help you sharpen
that intuition and know what the right
move is at the right time I agree you
know that's you know rookie mistakes
because they've not had enough game time
to be able to know that that thing is
about to happen in sports the problem is
which is different than some maybe you
know other professions is that as you
get older and have more experience your
intuition gets better but your physical
ability can start to decrease right so
you know you might be better in certain
ways but not in others but in in other
professions you know you don't have that
downside yeah that's why you want that's
why you like it when your doctor is
older you know because you know that
that doctor has a lot more experience so
the thing is Doctor when you what you've
just described the athlete that's aging
but the game experience and the
intuition is rising
a great athlete remains great by
adapting and surviving they know they no
longer have foot speed or they no longer
have certain aspects so they load other
areas to compensate for what is
diminishing and you see it so often and
I think with medical science and with
the actual understanding of how to
develop mental skills and strength
players like LeBron James going deep
into their 30s and still being almost at
the top isn't it already 40. LeBron I
don't want to I he's too big for me to
get his age wrong
I thought it's 40 Maybe not maybe not I
Heather there's something that we
haven't discussed but I think it it
relates to all of this
at one point in our conversation we said
that uh to to relieve some of your
stress just go out and make believe it's
practice you're just having just go have
fun well in sports where
you can set a world record
there is stress in the final race in the
final contest
that pushes you beyond any limit your
body mind has ever seen
and typically that doesn't that won't
happen in practice
so something is going on in the heads of
people
to do something that not only has no one
else done before neither have their own
body done before
what's going on inside the head of
someone that can go beyond themselves
it's it's I that's something that you
can't necessarily
uh consciously control so all these
other factors are coming into play let's
say it's you know it's the Olympics and
you're running that final race and
just being in that environment you know
with the audience and the lights and the
camera whatever is there is motivating
your body I mean we see this in in
cockroaches and okay
not with a big
whoa okay so I was not expecting that
sorry no no one was okay sorry sorry
there's something called the social
facilitation effect even in other
animals when a cockroach will run a
certain speed and when it's in the
presence of other cockroaches like
observing it it will run faster now I
don't know that it's consciously making
that decision and and we all know this
and somehow we perform differently when
we're alone versus if we know other
people watching us and you're not
consciously saying I'm gonna perform
differently because but but this input
is getting into your brain it's telling
you this is important or I want to
impress these people whatever it may be
um and it encourages you to go beyond
these limits but there's nothing you you
can tell yourself to make yourself do it
it's almost like you you have to get all
your skills and have everything ready to
go and just trust your body knows what
it's doing
um and one example I'll use is
um you know a friend who told me these
ones we were running we're going down
out and we were like going down and I
was like so nervous and taking it step
by step and you know I and he was just
going really quick and he said you gotta
just not think about it just let your
body go and it knows what it's doing and
you'll get down safer that way and there
was truth and those were the last words
he never spoke as I watched him tumble
away he was never seen again he was
never seen again
see the other thing doctor
it's a competitive streak in an
individual and then you have you hear
other phrases and the the one that
sounds stupid but actually does have
some Credence to it is Winners find a
way of winning
because that's what they want to do
that's what's going on in their mind the
other ones are things like the bigger
the game the big players turn up
and they bring a big performance with
them they don't cower in the corner and
they have this ability to rise to an
occasion they then I mean the other
Mantra you'll hear is if you if you're
playing in a big set police piece gain
don't play the game not the occasion so
they take away all the peripheral hype
and drama and noise It won't always be
good based on what Heather just told us
your other roaches are looking at you
yeah I know but then but then you see
you've got these other competitive
streaks now I didn't turn up because I
want to go home a loser I turned up
because I want to win otherwise I
wouldn't have bothered getting out of
bed and it's in this sort of attitude
that you find I mean maybe it's higher
stronger within certain individuals that
rise to the very top of the sports
yeah what you're talking about is
something a concept we call mindset
right and there's a lot of studies that
someone named um Carol dweck has has
done a lot of work on this but
um when you have a particular mindset it
can affect so many things down to your
basic physiology so this this one study
looked at people who were cleaners at
hotels and they would always be tired at
the end of the day and they measured all
their physiologic their body weights and
you know BMI and the rest of it and then
they started putting up these signs in
the break room saying that that that
cleaning is really good exercise and
it's really good for you and it actually
like burns calories and all these things
and they change their mindset about the
work and then their physiologic measures
started to improve they were doing the
same amount of work and there's a number
of studies like this but when is that if
you go into a situation saying I'm a
winner and you have this goal in mind
and this foresight and then your body
kind of comes along to meet that
expectation right if you really believe
it if you really and you compete with
yourself most of the best athletes are
trying to beat their own record it's not
as much about the other person about
beating their own you know Kobe Bryant
or whatnot was probably just trying to
beat himself right and that continues to
motivate you and keep you at the top of
the game but really having a goal and
and trusting that somehow your brain and
body will find a way to get there and
that's a positive mindset
cool yep all right well we gotta call it
quits there what that was a chalk full
episode man my brain is still digesting
all that plus the roaches I gotta think
of it I gotta think about that one how
much time is being roach on the floor
you know he has a whole different and
don't forget Neil never take a lizard
into a bar and get it drunk there you go
that was the lesson of the second one
don't get lizards drunk that's the worst
worst thing well Heather it's been a
delight to have you back on StarTalk
thanks for being such a loyal friend of
the show uh uh serving us up your
expertise when and where we need it and
Gary Chuck always good to have you guys
there it's a pleasure all right this has
been StarTalk sports edition of a an
episode on the focus of mine
I've been your host from Neil deGrasse
Tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
keep looking
[Music]